es un juicio que podrías estar un duro
golpe al expresidente de Brasil
bolsonaro acusado de abusar de su cargo
y de utilizar indebidamente los medios
de comunicación estatales será juzgado
ante el máximo tribunal electoral de
Brasil a partir de este jueves los
cargos surgieron de las acusaciones
infundadas que hizo durante una reunión
televisada en julio de 2022 en plena
carrera presidencial cuando puso en duda
la legitimidad y seguridad del sistema
de votación electrónico del país
hago la pregunta hoy porque aún estamos
a tiempo de resolver este problema con
la participación de las fuerzas armadas
que han sido invitadas por el Tribunal
Superior electoral
Nuestro objetivo es que haya
transparencia y confianza en las
elecciones gane quien gane El perdedor
debe aceptar el resultado
las declaraciones fueron transmitidas
por la televisión Estatal la fiscalía
afirma que su discurso pretendía socavar
la confianza de la ciudadanía en las
elecciones brasileñas mientras a su
defensa lo ha descrito como un acto de
gobierno que pretendía plantear
preocupaciones válidas sobre la
seguridad de las elecciones bolsonaro ha
criticado desde hace mucho tiempo los
sistemas de votación de Brasil y también
ha afirmado sin pruebas que dan cabida
al fraude si pierde el caso el político
de extrema derecha podría quedar
inhabilitado para presentarse a las
elecciones hasta 2030 Aunque este juicio
es solo uno de los problemas legales del
expresidente también se enfrenta a
varias investigaciones del tribunal
supremo que podrían ponerlo tras las
rejas entre ellas la acusación de que
incitó el asalto a la plaza de los tres
poderes el 8 de enero en Brasil